on this episode Beth Comstock and her
incredible new book are here I think
you're gonna love this episode
everybody's Gary Vaynerchuk this episode
291 of the askgaryvee show I'm super
excited about this we have somebody who
I've gotten to know very well in my
professional career in the last last
decade or so somebody I admire quite a
bit from afar and and really really
interestingly and this is fun for me to
say and it's fun for me to say with you
in the room I think I'm starting it on
this kick of saying nice or saying
things I believe that are nice about
people to them because I don't think we
do that that's nice
you'll like this one I - I think Beth I
admire you so much through the eyes of
others it's amazing you know we because
of the circles we run in for a lot of
even entrepreneurial II and author and
personalities and and corporate collide
into people that we both know there's a
lot of people that we both know yeah a
lot of them I'll meet for the first time
or things that nature however gets
brought up over the last five or six
years the one thing I've noticed is the
way people talk about you behind your
back with no vested interest is awesome
it's like I'd so dream about that's
what's happening with me and so maybe
that's why I take no that's nice see
where you're at the top if people if I
came out with a list of like top people
rankings that are having nice things
said about them behind them back with no
vested interest cuz people say nice
things about people but it's a move yeah
and I can trick so I know when that's
happening a lot thus it makes me like
you even more than I like you by myself
nice because I know it's a consistent
regardless of the scenario so that's the
interview I want to say you've got a new
book coming I didn't ask you coming out
coming out it's coming out Tuesday
September 18th amazing so here we are
and thank you for the blurb thank you
for asking me I was super flattered
we're gonna get into it in a minute so
Beth Comstock is in my opinion a dynamic
force in communication executives and
just human I'm gonna let her do her and
she added that part
yep if this was the you know if this was
comic book number one who are you and
I'm talking like I was born it like who
are what did you give me three four
minute I love context I think it frames
up everything and I'd like to get three
four minutes out of you I'm like who you
are like from coast to coast yeah well I
like that you know I was born cuz I grew
up in a small town in Virginia and my
parents came from West Virginia so you
know we talk about the southern accent
yeah so that was that was the Upper West
Virginia yeah real ya know my um
great-uncle started a newspaper
franchise in West Virginia called the
West Virginia hillbilly so I have real
deep hillbilly roots that is so there
you go so but I grew up in Virginia yep
my parents moved their small town as
they said small town girl it was a great
place to grow up I mean it was nurturing
my dad was a dentist my mom was a
schoolteacher it was real it was it
wasn't I have a brother and sister and I
just I that was my world
um yet I feel I felt like I wanted to
see the world you can read a lot I read
a ton so it's interesting you know like
it's funny why I ask questions I'm so
fascinated by communication I'm you know
I'm aware that you're not 19 but you're
also not 91 so your piece somewhere in
the middle right you're painting this
picture for me and I'm like okay a woman
of that generation in that scenario does
is it is it born in you your intuitively
like I'm a big city girl or was it
reading or TV like next if you said no
literally I would have said to you did
you watch the news a lot like did you
think Walter Cronkite was cool like to
me I'm fascinated by that stuff so go
ahead yeah no I think that's a good
question I mean it was two things for me
I think it was reading I spent every
summer like just devouring books I you
know I loved every I loved fiction like
crazy and then for me it was geography I
I loved I loved school
but I remember fifth grade like I would
get so excited about geography I just
like filling in the map fill the map but
like who are those people and who I've
recently joined the National Geographic
board and I'm so excited because it's
like that fifth grader again that's like
so that I think instilled in me there's
this whole world out
and what is it and my family didn't
travel a lot I mean we drove everywhere
I think I didn't get on an airplane
until I was until I was a CIA too from
high school that was my first trip weird
I was scared my mother was a school
teacher as I said and she took me on a
teacher sponsored trip to Europe and it
was at my first flight and I was 18 and
we could drink then and I ordered a
double gin and tonic yes and my mother
was like what the hell are you doing
yeah she's like I think she was just
shocked because I knew how to order a
double that's so cool okay so what
happens you you're a great student great
student I went to school in my home
state college women marry yep I funny I
just found this notebook and when I was
14 I found my autobiography when I was
14 no way there was not a lot to be
excited about when you take pictures of
I did I mean since I haven't put it yet
but I do have I will I will it was
really fun to see yeah it was fun but
but what I what I said in 14 my
autobiographies not as I'm ambitious I
want to be 50 different things in my
life and I said I want to see the world
so even at 14 I had that sense wow the
14 of euros the 14 year old version of
you nailed it yeah it was amazing really
nailed it yeah although I did say I
wanted to be a lawyer at one point and
there's 50 things I I know I live all in
one day did you ever want to be a lawyer
no I know I wanted to be I've only found
one thing ever that showed me my whole
life I thought I wanted to be you know
businessman cuz it really was early for
me yeah so I was like yeah but I was
devastated I found a picture of me in
kindergarten and said I wanted to be a
cowboy and I was like [ __ ] but didn't
you maybe grow up to be a cowboy that
listened interpretations are fun okay
very cool so you went to school exam
what happens then I go to school I
studied biology thought I was gonna go
to medical school okay but what I really
wanted to do is I got into it was I
wanted to be a science reporter intro so
because I was a biology major I tried to
take more writing classes and we were
you like really into TV I was into TV
I wanted to just report and so but but
you wanted a report on TV I did wanna
report on T so there's a fun dynamic
there knowing now enough about you
Monday morning quarterbacking it calms
come you like like that's an interesting
part cuz I think some people made the
like like default into vanity and I
default into scale yeah I just I mean to
me that I cuz I grew up watching TV I
was a kid of TV but um my first job was
my last year what can i apologize
what was your favorite TV show as a kid
you think there were so many
rattle off a few cuz this will be fun
for B persons well I was a kid who
watched reruns after school every day so
these do you know like I Dream of
Jeannie Gilligan's Island I don't know
like they're all from the 50s and snow
those loved those shows the Brady Bunch
I mean all those kind of things I loved
those I was my core thing coming up
their school reruns Three's Company the
facts of life
no the 2d was his 2d okay you're really
this might the bowl bath we better stay
focus here because this might turn into
an entire podcast TV trivia I don't know
you I literally was about to say 2d I
think Shirley ray just passed away she
did okay so you want to be a science
reporter so and besides mrs. Garrett for
everybody who out there that was the UM
but so my real quick Beth I'm sorry I'm
very help the skelter I know everyone's
mad at me do you know that mrs. Garrett
first appeared on Diff'rent Strokes and
that spun off the facts of life no I
didn't know that BAM I didn't know that
all right go ahead so yeah and then my
first job was I was a senior in college
and I worked in public radio I worked in
the local public radio station in
Norfolk Virginia and I remember going
home to my hometown and have it was
spending a day with the migrant Apple
pickers and they were singing beautiful
songs as they picked their apples and I
was just smitten I wanted to be a
storyteller Wow
so then I tried to work my way and I had
no confidence so my first job I went to
work covering the Virginia House of
Delegates for like c-span of Virginia in
the day and I did everything I worked
behind the camera I learned
register camera I learned to edit I was
in front of the camera I was like a
Jacke of all trades I and and I tried to
get my first job
I apologize real quick right now this is
gonna be the most meta thing ever
because I'm gonna wear this in four
months like on a flight somebody's gonna
see it and they're gonna be blown away
that it exists I'm not kidding make a no
Caleb
I want a Jackie of all trades t-shirt
made I want somebody to draw it we have
that skill see get Cesar on it right now
he's gonna kill it I want a Jackie of
all trades t-shirt made and I'm going to
wear it I wanna I wanna I want to see
that you want look I would like to
thanks Molly to three and I'm not
kidding I want it to be rare because I'm
gonna sell mine on eBay one day three
t-shirts
Jackie ball trades Molly beth me ACK I
think I don't know you know
jack-of-all-trades I was racquetball
trades
Jackie ball trades t-shirt women's cut
for them like you know these gonna be
premium like yeah no bones no bulky
thing yeah no okay okay
to get sizes you know what I love about
this somebody's gonna see your name on
the podcast and they're like they're
like people that don't follow me they're
gonna see that really cool I want to
listen to that and then be like I
definitely didn't think that mrs.
Garrett in the facts of life and a
jack-of-all-trades t-shirt conversation
would be going on I didn't answer
this is not necessarily the format so
one story about trying to make it as a
TV reporter was I lacked confidence yes
and I but I also had a resilience at the
same time so I was working in Richmond
Virginia and I finally had a tape
because as Jackie of all trades I did
get to make a tape every now and then I
got to interview a few members of the
House of Delegates so I I made it a
thing to send my tape to the local TV
station it was channel 12 Richmond
Virginia and the news director would
never take my call he would never do
anything but I called every day I called
every day at about lunchtime
I would call him and finally after about
four six months he said he picked up
they finally he picked up the phone he
goes listen you're never I'm never gonna
hire you you looked
young you have no experience why would I
ever hire someone who looks as young as
you really you're you're not gonna make
it in this business and I was devastated
but after that I like was speechless
like I'd never had anyone speaking like
but after that it was like this this
sort of anger grew up in me I was like
you don't know me did you say that or
did you hang up I hung up and I hung up
I got it I got it I look at me I'm a
character and I've had those kind of
moments I get that so you hang up and
you went quickly did you go I'm very
curious about this question Beth did you
go sad for the day for lunch for a week
for a month or did you literally go sad
to that place in your hello I went dead
for a couple of days probably weeks even
cuz I sucked my support I was like cuz
again I didn't have a lot of confidence
and I was like well this guy says I'm
gonna make it I call ended up Kona miss
Durant in my head I'm sure I could go
down to his find his name and find his
name I would have to do anything yeah
thank you good but mr. rant is what I
called him and and it just grew and me
like he doesn't know me he does love me
and so that always was pivotal to me
because this was this kind of rebel this
this resilience like I got a show this
is a really interesting time to say
something Beth and I have had a really
nice professional group that meant like
we're both so busy in the data it's
really interesting literally as you're
telling this story this specific piece
I'm like and that's that week literally
up until this moment you're kind I think
about how I introduced this literally
until this second net like literally now
I'm like oh this is why we still I've
met many executives there's lots of
executives like this kinship towards you
that I've never really fully I've
actually up until four seconds ago
always leaned on kind this you being
pissed about that's fine but III
understand the Mack I'm sure plenty of
people you know the macro is the macro
the this thing is the thing yeah but I I
mean you're making me remember that
whole time of just trying to get started
in a career I I from there I find I
sort of worked a network my my dad was
helping me trying to like get people he
knew and we we were small town yeah he
did two interesting things one when I
was still in college he he had a patient
who he was a dentist and he had a
patient who was a CBS news producer in
Washington which was about two hours
away I'm sure he got him in this like
LOC home like his mole earlier now he's
like my daughter wants to get into
television what can you do for this guy
said well I work within Diane Sawyer who
was a young a young reporter at the
State Department not the Diane Sawyer
she came to be did you know who that was
and I think bear honestly I really
didn't and so I got to go and shadow her
at a day at eight depart the [ __ ] out of
yeah and she was so incredibly she was
just starting out yeah he just gotten
back from Chad or something but I you
know I would look for those little
moments was just a fluke thing that jump
in here you know I can this is how I
helped her skelter like and then of
course you've gotten you've met her no
this is fun
more fun by the second I'm soaked
through me per loop are you telling me
in the last 20 years you've never run
into Diane Sawyer I have but I've never
said hi to her you are whole Diane
Sawyer right now real quick real quick
team clip this give it to me I'm
tweeting at night this is gonna be huge
you you've seen her at events or not in
medium a circuit CBS I worked it in BC
like I worked at way DNA that's helped
me you know cuz it's getting more fun
that how many times have you been in the
physical same room or conference as
Diane Sawyer how many times I've been in
any mess with her at least probably two
or three times and once I had this sense
that I was gonna go say remember you
would not remember this but you made a
big impression on me and I lost my nerve
you would have made her do you want I
don't know I was a long saving you time
you would have made bet you were such an
all-time accomplished executive I
understand
I thought maybe you're not a dummy
meaning you're aware of what you've
accomplished
you would make I basically think I'm
living my life right now
trying to do as much for all these young
people on one thesis in 29 years some
crazy successful people are gonna roll
up I mean be like one tweet you made
like I can't wait for Beth Comstock to
come up to me and say you me Beth this
is crazy I know I know well I didn't see
her lay I saw her like mid career let's
say but I was just - I have like I don't
know I was just like what do I say like
hey you say hey Diane Sawyer do you
remember in 1900 I told you and I think
the biggest question is she's you're
right to your point she'll probably not
remember oh no it was she mind because
you might like here's where life's
awesome you might have said something
weird I didn't say anything but no I was
such a good girl like know what I say I
apologize I use funny sight I use words
not the right way you might have said
something that caught her attention or
started a thought or maybe that day
later at home something that made you
remember maybe you were wearing blue
shoes and something like you have to do
this right yeah yeah you know that how
many of you were watching live on
Facebook good can the 350 people on
Facebook right now
tweet both Beth Comstock and Diane
Sawyer and tell them what's going on
right now thank you
yeah oh yeah but she had great advice
for me when I met her she was all true
yeah she said cuz I was like I want to
be a reporter and she's old here's what
I want you to do I still remember cuz
this is the impact people like you have
on keep going young people and so she
was like my brother was graduated from
high school that night and she said okay
here's what I want you to do tonight
when your brother's graduating you have
to have perspective you can't go and
think it's your brother you have to
assume he's not your brother
what what's he doing there what story
are you telling and I again like that
two-hour session just meant the world to
me that was awesome yeah so I never I
never I never but that was a pattern for
me good news we fixed it yeah we didn't
fix it look at fixing go ahead tell me
more or less pattern well no I mean this
one I put in the book in the sense that
I shared a very similar version of this
when I worked at sea
for a year you want to CNN I worked the
scene for two years what years we've
been night early 90s and it was during
the first Gulf Wars yeah that's like for
all the youngsters that is the moment
that the enemy CNN during the first Gulf
War because it was 24/7 full access it
was almost the closest thing I could
tell you to the Internet it was a 22 for
being my generation translator yeah I'm
trying to help these kids but so Ted
Turner who was at his day the
swashbuckling yeah Steve Jobs of the
media world of that day they disrupted
traditional medias and I did PR for a
kid on occasion for him and I worked
there for a year and he didn't know my
name okay and so I decided I was gonna
change all that and I finally got up my
nerve chips on shoulder so unlike Diane
Sawyer where I never said hello I
finally got up my nerve and I picked the
worst time possible I saw him going into
the men's room we were at the UN flat
awaiting an award he goes into the men's
room and I go now's my chance as one
does and so he's coming out of the men's
room and there I am and I'm like hi Ted
and he goes oh hi and his southern
accent and he gives me this incredibly
wet slimy yes and shake
keep going and he kind of looked at me
like what do you got to say and I froze
I'm gonna look down and he walked away
and he zipped up his fly and he never
knew my name but it was that moment
where I I just said to myself like who
did it like I didn't care you were
pumped I said hi to him your pump I was
pumped I was no longer like I stepped
away from the waffle I said hi yes and I
gave myself permission to get in there
now I really want to help people in the
world not kidding how old were you when
this happened I was 30 this is important
this is super important I talk a lot
about lately 18 22 and 30 Oh interesting
yeah these are three nuts it's funny
these three ages are really playing with
me people are putting disproportionate
pressure on themselves at these points
in their lives when we're still
remarkably young you are like a big deal
to a lot of people and for them to hear
a story that you were thrilled
that you were awkwardly saying hello to
somebody and that was the net
accomplishment there was no next
conversation there was no he heard
something profound from you and didn't
even hear my name I I hear it it's
unbeliev let me tell you about me at 30
I was packing boxes in a liquor store at
11:30 at night on December 21st because
I want to get packages out for people
the next day this needs to be talked
about that is why say 18 and 22 what's
going on then I'm just looking at a lot
of money you know I listen a lot there's
a anxiety at 18 22 and 30 that is
remarkably high to me 18 I think you're
making that transition into college 22
you're making that [ __ ] you know or even
if you're not going to college you think
you should be or this and that they're
just watershed moments the transition of
graduation yeah because because
regardless depending on who you are
you've decided you're a grown up in all
three of those ages different than other
numbers 18 you're a grown up
I guess 21 could throw it but I'm 18 22
I'm a grown up 30 holy [ __ ] I don't have
my [ __ ] together I'm a grown up those
three are playing with me I'm packing
boxes in a liquor store packing by I
mean in the warehouse you are thrilled
that you this is important Beth because
people think they have to have
everything figured out 20900 you don't
this is a and you know what's happening
bad behavior
yeah things that lead to depression
things that lead to substance abuse
things that lead to bad relationships
things that lead to you know many people
you don't Beth you know how many people
maxed out their credit cards to buy
Bitcoin at fifteen thousand I would I'll
tell you a ton of people saw it go from
you know you saw what happened and they
bought at the top with credit cards
because people are saying you have to
and I'm getting the emails cuz I'm me oh
my god horrible there do you know what
paying 12% interest on a hundred
thousand on a thing that's underwater
like why do they do that because they
wanna buy a plane because they want to
be successful so anyway I don't know I'm
sorry too this is the purpose of this
format for different stories this is a
powerful to me maybe I'm reacting to it
you
at 30 just happy to say hello yeah and I
bring it up because it is that moment
where you're pushing yourself to do
something you're not comfortable with
yes as a reserved shy person I realized
I was standing in my own way too you
know I mean I would I would go to
meetings and people didn't know who I
was I'd worked this guy for a year and
he didn't know who I was I mean it
wasn't like his you know I wasn't his
office everyday but you weren't in the
mix I was in the mix but yet I wasn't
taking advantage of it and so there are
those moments when you got to say like
I'm holding myself back and that was one
of those moments for me where it's you
know you're grabbing your own agency
like I got to do this good for you and
then the momentum built and then
momentum builds from there and you know
i I've used that approach to getting
over introversion you know I'm really
the life of the party I'm accept that
and I go to a event and you know
everybody's meeting hey I'm you know and
I'm the first one over by the chip Bowl
or at the back of the room and I've had
that's another for another place I've
had to say okay I'm gonna go meet one
person like I would never probably have
come and met you but I would go find
somebody else who looked like they were
okay talking to me and you just then the
next time I see two people the next time
then I feel like now I'm gonna go talk
to Gary Vee and but that's after you
know it's behavior modification it's
after ten times I'm finally the
confidence and less awkward to do that I
love this real quick cuz now I'll speed
up a little because I wanna get the book
and I want answer a couple questions so
from CNN give me now speed up the
episode one so I worked I worked in a
couple of different I worked at CBS and
I came back to NBC and nBC will I worked
at NBC News it was a formative job for
me I loved that job is one of my best
jobs ever the news division had
undergone a real issue that they almost
blew up the whole news division because
of a scandal oh really and for me it was
one of my most what I loved about it was
entrepreneurial and I think that was my
awakening that you can be an
entrepreneur and a big company good and
really kind of created a path for me and
then I worked my way through NBC ended
up going to GE I got a call one day what
was the last job you had at NBC well I
went to G came back a couple of times my
last job was I led digital media at NBC
and I oversaw ad sales and then
new stuff and new things were a village
in hulu so we had one that didn't go so
well and one that went really well
keep going then jack and then i well
before that i I got on the GE radar and
Jack Woltz called me up to his office
one day and said I want you to come and
work at GE that was the last thing from
my mind
sure I was gonna be in media my whole
life why would I go to GE def lean and I
mean he was on his way up to Jack Welch
the icon at that point he hadn't quite
hit the big time but he was this he was
CEO and he had said he was gonna it was
important the company was doing well I
mean he was gonna retire in four years
and in that four years I worked with him
he really sort of became superstar CEO
of his day and I learned a lot from that
opportunity but what I'd say from that
is I didn't think I why would I go to GE
I owned NBC but but there was just
something I felt I had it was an
opportunity I could see the world I
could learn something new was to see the
world the big one I think to see the
world was that the one I think that was
it and I remember standing by the
elevator after I had announced I was
going to GE and one of my NBC colleagues
was like you know they saw lightbulbs
right like you're leaving NBC to go sell
light bulbs I get it and I was like yeah
and I'm excited about it yeah I didn't
know why but that's always I guess a
theme for me I kind of picked these
things anyway and so from there I just
spent the bulk of my career doing
marketing and innovation work at GE
seating businesses pushing for change
and that became my thing it's really
cool what's the book about the books
about pushing for change I'm pretty
consistent yeah and what I tried to do
with the book is make it very personal
and share stories early to make career
I'm really trying to reach people early
to make career to say you know we've all
had to start somewhere and you just
gotta get out of your way and don't ask
permission and or give yourself
permission and try to make change happen
I try to highlight the bad behavior that
we all have to deal with at work when
people want to make change happen and
share my stories of things that didn't
work things that works so that's what
I'm trying to do with it hopefully
inspire with the story give people
practical tools and we intentionally
call imagine it forward it's about how
we need people to fight for the future
of our companies and make change happen
I love it
Andy give us a
question since it is the askgaryvee show
oh yeah you better talk about execution
creativity taking risks etc how do we
make sure our future generations inherit
we learned that failure is a stepping
stone
since our education system lacks
education your thoughts I love that
question I would have written that
question if I could have and that's why
the cover of my book has this wad of
rainbow paper because it is about there
is a failure message here and I love
this question because we're not doing
that I worry just deeply about how we're
educating our kids you talk to any high
school teacher college professor they'll
tell you people are students are anxious
about not knowing the answer about
having to be perfect so I don't know how
are you raising your kids that way I I
tried to instill in my kids creativity
taking risks as much as I could I'm sure
I wasn't perfect but I feel like we
don't do enough of that in our school
system I mean I genuinely believe I'm
the poster child in the other direction
well no no I mean my kids they're nine
and six I got I got a little ways to go
but I'll get to that in a minute
I'm I'm literally making content on the
internet that says fail on purpose yeah
yeah like I'm I literally make content
every day that says the reason I'm
successful is cuz I failed my whole life
yeah I was a terrible student I was told
that I wasn't gonna be good
like nothing pointed to my success in
the system I was playing in except for
me and my mom and in my head so like I I
[ __ ] on 8th place trophies I hate I just
posted a video I literally posted a
video this morning that's that I knew
wasn't gonna do well called fake
environments and left the comment and
said I knew this wasn't gonna do well as
none of you want to deal with this
reality that if your parents pay just
for your uber you're already living in a
fake environment like I'm pushing I'm
about to get really unpopular because
I'm gonna write a parenting book that's
gonna make every single parent in
America not like me so I'm very
passionate about this and so what am I
gonna do let me give you an example what
I do I tell a five-year-old boy that
he's not gonna be in the NBA when he
looks
at me and says he's going to be yeah
which then is going to create a reaction
maybe is I don't know but what I'll tell
you is it's highly unlikely yeah yeah
because I'm not giving him that DNA
yeah but or it does create this
resiliency right it's the no not yet
often I but I'm definitely not gonna say
you sure are little I yeah somebody did
what for you because you thought yeah
yeah look as a player to you're not good
you're good really I and you could see
it cuz when he plays with us or the
couple times I've seen play he's rusty
but you can see it's there but the fact
that this [ __ ] kid who I've if you
knew the story of how this man is
sitting here like and hat like how right
insane like how he what he did to be
here meaning I gave a talk of Babson how
he kept reaching out I challenged him by
letting him commute for no money to Wine
Library for a year people here who are
like that how there's a lot right is
that kind of your hiring method we do we
do a lot of different things but
obviously these are my favorites this
kid had the ability to make no money and
travel to New Jersey from New York to
work at a liquor store
like there's a million things but the
fact that I know all these things about
him that I think are remarkable and the
fact that he was that [ __ ] delusional
at 18 that he thought he was gonna be a
basketball player speaks to the power of
fake environments yeah yeah the fact
that he spoke up like and said like it's
a big it's a big couple things on tad I
think we we need to put our kids and our
colleagues in situations that they got
to figure it out I used to have this
fantasy that we would create a class at
GE where I would send people to I don't
know Akron yep and we'd take their cell
phone away and said you gotta figure
your way back to New York
I like how do you do that right I would
accommodate that kind of [ __ ] cuz we
gotta end with our kids too we can't
have him have all the answers a lot of
people here do that like that's what I
do to my team I don't tell the Indian I
don't talk to Andy and he runs my team I
don't talk to him Andy do I talk to you
like I am loved but that's the that's
the future how do you figure it out how
it makes it difficult because he doesn't
talk to you
[ __ ] yeah because I have to lose and win
on my own and learn yeah
and then if Kerry doesn't like something
you'll hear about it but that's also the
candor that you need right that I'm
super so like I'm the like I deliver
vinegar with like honey in and honey out
right like the way I manage is like look
let's put this in the context verse I
[ __ ] love you and cannot believe what
you're doing now real quick what the
[ __ ] were you thinking about that dumb
[ __ ] and then like and by the way you're
[ __ ] killing it let's keep going
right I'm like because that's the truth
yeah it's the truth and but the favorite
thing you mentioned you're putting it
out there but we what what is it we like
have this fail fast fail small like no
one really you can't just fail fast and
fail small you have to take real risk
and I want that useful to your point
I know it's just people aren't willing
to take risk these days Beth because
we're living in one big fake environment
right now we bailed ourselves we should
just be coming out of a depression let's
let's really play yeah let's talk about
America okay I don't want to speak this
is where I really no answer to your
question or your statement we should
just be coming out of a recession a deep
recession we bailed ourselves out the
last 7 to 10 years this is my world now
and you're close to it because you're a
leader from a corporate world which is
startup culture is where I'm going Beth
we're still in the midst of a world
where somebody goes to a liberal arts
school is wired into the ecosystem of
wealth pops out never sold a thing or
has a business bone in their body and
gets funded comes you're too smart for
me you didn't let me build it up
literally comes up with an idea not only
do they get funded it's worth 4 million
dollars they're 22 years old you thought
of something
999 thousand billion could trillion out
of almost every time it's a bad idea but
it is now worth 4 million dollars and
people that are fancy and smart and Beth
and Gary Vee give you money to go I mean
we are in a fake [ __ ] so I have like
look you know you're busy but like I've
evolved quite a bit ya know you realize
I'm great to see the height of my career
in Silicon Valley I started in the
agency let's start there before even my
evolution actions 2009 I have all the
leverage and I go start a client service
business all my Silicon Valley what's
the matter with you want to talk about
life
still like you can raise 100 million
dollars and make to you what are you
doing to go to go make a picture make
tweets for Linda Babaji eat like this is
like this is what was going on in the
backdrop I just wanted to be practical I
just didn't want a fake environment
I just wanted to operate yeah I like the
way you're framing that of the fake
environment is interesting really good
one you know and why are a lot in
business too I mean this is why you know
we're really pleased and this is where
in our little ecosystem our key you
wanna talk about our kids you have older
kids if you ask me the biggest fear I
have fake environment let me tell you
what's really going on this is just deep
and I want to get this off because I'm
so passionate it feels like the right
time to talk about it there are people
out there who have startups whose daddy
or mommy is underwriting it quietly the
only two people that know sometimes is
mom and the son not even a dad knows
that they're kicking cash to keep it
alive
cuz the mom or the dad or the kid or the
boy or the girl they all like the facade
that little Johnny's doing well mom's
kick in cash because she wants her
friends to think her son or daughter is
the next mark [ __ ] suck mean fake
environments and then kids complained
you know kids complain like my parents
[ __ ] me up but then don't take the
money and I'm talking about the gym pass
like if you want your parents to have no
say a lot of times kids you know I get a
lot of family dynamics Gary I love you
you're right I'm [ __ ] my mom and dad
you're right I'm like be careful let's
start over
are they giving you money yeah well then
they have control then [ __ ] you yeah if
you want to go to SoulCycle every
weekend and you're taking Mama's money
and you're not earning it guess what
Mama's in charge what do people say back
to you and you say that [ __ ] they're
like you know they got like you got me
dammit I thought you were on my team I'm
like no no I'm on the team of merit
if your parents are insecure and are
making you become an engineer because it
makes them look good at a cocktail party
they're bad if you are mad at your
parents for creating entitlement but
you're taking the cash because you want
to go on the cruise with your buddies to
[ __ ] Ibiza you're bad but I'm in the
corner of the truth yeah got it
yeah yeah yeah you really have grown
alive
you know what's funny I've just
communicated a lot if you think about it
in our first interactions I was pushing
social medias ROI in a way that nobody
yeah I remember meeting you over
breakfast in at South by Southwest yep
in Austin yeah I think that was one of
our first things and just your passion
and it was like clear you just you were
gonna make this happen
100% I do believe that people it was
actually I was listening to you and I
had that feel a little bit there is no
question
things that I see every day that I'm
like oh that person is legitimately
gonna will this to success yeah it's
starting off as a sushi restaurant and
she might sell diapers in Afghanistan
but that is going to work yeah yeah that
was a great question Andy good job
do it do it and I'll keep you up a
little bit that's your isn't my first
book is right yeah a lot of us
it was a lot of work I don't know writer
Toras yes all writers so that was
helpful
go ahead no so I it's just it was a lot
because it's a very personal book yeah I
have precious with it well I I just feel
exposed a bit I'm nervous about I'm
nervous because nobody left out there
that as a reserved person it was it was
against my nature in some ways to be
open about the things I put failure in
it yep
so it was a very emotionally draining
book in that respect cuz I had to really
dig deep to go like what was I feeling
okay you didn't really handle that well
like there I talk a lot in here about
some tension especially with a couple
people and I had to go back it was so
easy to go what you're saying he was a
jerk good for you but no like Jesus
Karen Karen Karen Karen Karen Karen this
is Gary Vaynerchuk I think you're you're
one you're watching this right now right
I can hear in the background could you
lower it
okay I think okay I slipped it off now
okay great hello hello Karen say hello
to Beth Comstock hi Karen how are you
good how are you very good thank you
do you have a question for us yes um I'm
here in Vancouver Canada and I'm
basically trying to advocate for mothers
who are professional method but who have
been out of the workforce for a long
period of time 5 10 15 years they might
have been Nick menaces or senior
managers and they would like to go back
to work and now the question I have is
on a corporate management level because
that's where I'm going next how do I
convince somebody what you were at GE
how do I go to them and say this is mom
this was amazing
she doesn't have paid work experience in
the last ten years but before that she
was brilliant so how do I convince them
to take a chance Karen I love this
question and I can also tell how hard it
how hard it is
so one thanks for putting it out there
one I would start with saying what and
you know whatever's happened over the
past it's not that you were brilliant
and then you want to wait 10 years and
now you have to reestablish it you're
still brilliant so how do you package
that so some part of it is just
packaging yourself what it what are some
things you've been doing maybe there's
some things you've been working at at
your kids school at a community project
that you could start to say I've been
doing marketing or I'm a community
organizer so some of it is just
packaging what you've been doing and
letting people see those organizational
skills or those promotion skills or
operations skills that you have that
would be the first thing to what Gary
was saying earlier to his team here I
think you you kind of have to keep
bugging people you have to sort of get
in their face a little bit into the
story we were talking about earlier you
got a 1 do some homework do some you
know look for companies where you see
some of the leadership
case maybe you'd look for some women
leaders who may be your mom's and maybe
you'd find a conference where a couple
of them are speaking and go ask them
afterwards like hey could I show you my
resume is there someone on your team who
could look at it look at it so try to do
some homework and look for people who
you think might just have a conversation
with you and give you some feedback and
the last thing I'd say is I feel better
about corporate the corporate world that
they're recognizing that there's great
talent in mothers who have been taking
care of their kids and not in the
workforce and so a lot of companies are
creating job shares I think with this
notion of the quote gig economy there's
a lot more happening to give people
project work so maybe the first thing is
maybe your first thing won't be to get a
job there but can you take a project on
that would allow them to see what you're
capable of on a project component and
then it's a way to start to get them to
know you and you to know them I really
think that's gonna be the future of
hiring anyway we're more of us in the
corporate setting are gonna be doing
these kind of limited run assignments to
see if we want to work together okay I'm
gonna jump in here let me tell you what
stands out for me I think you need to
focus on a couple things one as somebody
who's been selling things that other
people don't want to buy his whole life
the biggest thing this is an important
point that we need to tap into Andy the
biggest thing that I will tell you is do
not try to sell somebody who's not
sellable okay when something that is so
right like what you're saying like I've
always been think I've always thought I
was so right the and and history would
prove me out right and that's what in my
career but the problem is that when
you're selling something early people
don't see it right you are so right like
like you're talking I'm like man I want
to I want the next 30 people I hire at
Vayner to be that because managing a
family is a skill and a half that Maps
so well then people management is
everything like I'm in yeah they're
doing so many things at once yeah so
we've had conversations here about this
because we think it's a white space but
I promise you
at an enormous amount of organizations
call it 99 aren't interested in what you
just said
at this moment I'm and I'm not trying to
be debbie downer I just know the game
right now there's a lot of pushback what
most people do and whether it's 90
percent or 70 percent it's irrelevant
about 99 to 70 but I promise you it's
higher than anybody would like to think
it's a sad truth of the reality of the
situation regardless of that most people
when they are so right on something so
right get ideological they go into I'm
gonna prove to that know that this is
right and they punch against a wall
versus spending all their time to Beth's
earlier point of finding the yeses in a
city and by the way Beth and Linda buff
and Paul Markham were my yes in 2011
that was a big company named GE in a
world that I looked around and they said
yes to social and Vayner and made an
enormous bet on me and so did Pepsi and
Bannen and other and many many other I
didn't spend a second and I Karen I did
not spend a second pitching my services
to anybody that showed signals to me
that they were in the know business I
wasn't ideological I went to where there
was opportunity
Beth is unbelievably right and I will
triple down on it more homework on the
people that are ideologically aligned
with you on the importance of this like
do not get it twisted it's a sad state
of affairs she's absolutely right that
female leadership is gonna do a better
job for you they're gonna have more
empathy you're gonna have a character
once in a while like me cool but you've
got to really look for that and you got
to look for my content that showed you
that I would live on LinkedIn and watch
what people are putting out there and
then focus on 13 to 15 organizations
that have given you signals that they're
open to this and get slowly but surely
and then when you prove it out that it
works at you know Google or smoogle or
Corona or wherever then you could start
building on that case study I am blown
away by people spending all their time
trying to convince the nose because it's
like a fulfilled prophecy such that such
great advice I tried to build
my reputation is someone who was open to
anyone with a good idea and I have
people who would just call me with a
great send me a great email and I'd say
I want to see you I'm rare - I'm rare
yeah
but to your point we are out there a
hundred percent did Karen makes sense
right yes yes that is so helpful thank
you so much thanks for watching okay
[Laughter]
what else should we cover what else
should people know about this book I
really you know I really do want the
vaynernation to go out and pick this up
I think this is gonna thank you yeah I
mean I'm really trying to give people a
pocket of encouragement to just grab
permission and make change happen don't
wait for one of my quotes that I love
and there is like who are you waiting
for to tell you it's okay if you're late
to the pub keep going know your mother
keep going here well your boss your
mother
Yoda right I mean who are you waiting
for your who you're waiting for so yes
that's the basic and I just share little
hacks of things I did and what was that
authority in there that you said it this
one was on me you see we start to talk
before we did the phone call about
taking ownership and when it was easy to
say it was him what give me the oh well
no I mean I I have a particular chapter
in there about the last time I was at
NBC and it was a very tense time and I
literally had just real arguments with
one of the people I had to work with and
I shared engineer and I share it in the
in the book pretending yeah and did they
reach out to you not yet no but what I
had to do was to go back and go put
myself in his position
imagine him at the time the business
wasn't doing well
I look like a competitive threat that
they had been pitted planted from
headquarters that's right I was
challenging behind a tradition with the
cool kid approach to digital and I was
coming in a bit like I'm not a kid with
all this these digital tools imagine
that and me coming in there and I didn't
have that perspective then and I wish I
had so that's some of what I was trying
to do and for you at this point and
you've talked about it the matically
through here either you're born with it
it can develop but once you actually tap
into empathy you can become unstoppable
yeah the reason I didn't get mad that
nobody wanted to and to this day the
reason I can deal with how much pushback
I get
because of my I have to have empathy for
I have a specific personality type that
on initial consumption is going to turn
off people and like by the way I need
the sanest I wish I didn't you know I
wish and I know it's funny you reacted
mighty not a listen you get all the pros
of being a character but what you lose
is you start to become
disproportionately underestimated in
your intellect nothing has ever talked
about how smart I am like this is why
you couldn't have bill what you've built
without being smart yeah but it takes a
while for people to like wrap their head
around that right that's exactly right
but it takes time plus you have to build
it yes if they eat [ __ ] during the yeah
yeah you know to have the appetite to
eat [ __ ] like to me I like being it
doesn't it give you a bit of a
competitive advantage when people
underestimate you that it's the greatest
gift of all time I manipulate mice I
continue to suppress my own success
because I think it's that big of a
advance yeah I think I can relate I
think as a woman in business I had
something similar in the sense of I had
to work extra hard I had 100 but I also
think as a creative person that is why I
had to fight against that but being a
woman I was perhaps allowed to be a bit
more creative and I think sometimes in
certainly in business world and creative
men may have a harder time just like
expressing their creativity
I think it's right you know it's funny
you know I looked at a picture you know
it's really interesting I because I'm an
immigrant because I was a bornus country
because boy being Jewish in Eastern
Europe post-world War two my family's
stories are just unbearable ten years in
jail like real [ __ ] I've you know but
it's interesting I've always kind of
leaned there I got to tell you being an
F student like like I I tap so heavy
into the underdog thing and it just
makes so much sense of me and what I
actually what's so amazing is the
Internet
for real know like we I don't think
we've quantified this yet it's going to
bring such an advantage to people that
deal with adversity on the come up and
it's such a disadvantage to entitlement
hmm fake environments you're in trouble
adversity you're gonna win cuz the
platform reward
Marit yeah gonna be very interesting
it's gonna get real interesting yeah
well I think it's interesting a
meritocracy is not real it depends on
who sets the standards and yeah and I I
think I've just clued in to that in the
past few years just as you see that I
mean certainly the me to movement women
are we've been seeing this for a while
who set the standards I once did a panel
with somebody out of Silicon Valley and
he said you know we're not gonna lower
our standards and that's why we don't
have any more women and I was like who
set the standards how do you know the
standards couldn't be higher if you had
more women oh but this is why I tell all
my anybody who feels that they're being
not not at this seat at the table
aka anybody who isn't an old white male
right I basically say the same thing to
them like [ __ ] them don't play their
game yeah go create your own [ __ ]
game you own it
the internet go cut like right like
you're not getting money from venture
capitalists go get money from
high-net-worth individuals like a makes
you more creative don't play the game
yeah yeah like nothing make them back to
like some themes here vaynermedia was
built on the fact that I didn't play the
agency game like I just didn't know it's
driven you I think a hundred percent
yeah and you know I love that about you
that you're still trying to disrupt the
and there's not much left to disrupt for
some of them but you're right that
you're still like that hunger like I
know a different in a better way to do
it a hundred percent because it's very
real
yeah right like you're on the right side
of history and because I'm building this
machine for myself yeah I remember you
like when you were trying to get more
into advertising you like just give me a
shot just give me a shot we're good our
creatives gonna be the best and if it's
not we're gonna come back and make it
the best and you did like you just kept
working and I don't think people
appreciate that is what it takes I think
that's right I think you know I'm so
glad I'm gonna wrap up here in a minute
I'm I'm just so grateful that you told
that Ted Turner story you can't imagine
I'm gonna clip that I think you're gonna
change a lot of you
you know I have a very deep
understanding of what's going on with
communication right now I don't think
you understand I'm telling you don't
you're gonna be so pumped cuz we're
gonna talk about this in nine years you
don't know what that did Wow okay I'm
telling you about this 30-year old thing
Beth like like I'm telling you there's
been such a broken narrow inter
yeah and I just pulled some photos of
myself when I was thirty cuz I there is
something in my head about that was that
story but it's interesting you're saying
that now for me now that you're saying
that I'm thinking thirty was a big year
for me and you know you know we got
unlucky and I'll say that you find it
funny I wish you were 31 or 32 I don't
even even narrow in on that it's this
almost everybody in this entitled
environment thinks that they have to
have everything figured out at 26 29 32
31 meanwhile nobody has anything figured
out ever no I mean I was I I had I by 30
I had been married and divorced and and
had a kid and was working on my second
marriage and on my way to a second kid
and I didn't know what my job was gonna
be I came from a small town where we
didn't have a lot of connections right I
mean aside from my dad with producer
with a mole or a crippled but you know
you you yeah you have to get out and
just try things and kind of be resilient
love it Beth thank you for this yes
thanks for you getting in this show you
get the guest gets to ask the question
of the day so what's fun about the
question today is we're gonna get
thousands of responses now this is this
is where you can go theoretical selfish
here's what I mean by that you can ask a
question where you can get a lot of
insight there's a lot of people watching
there'll be a lot of answers so I tend
to like to use it for focus groups you
can ask a random thing that's just been
on your mind it could be about something
that's happening in culture like on
Netflix or on your app or about the book
or the concept or anything you want what
is your question of the day I'm gonna go
back to the question you got what do we
need to do to push for more creative
problem-solving in the world what are
your ideas who's doing it well I'm just
eager to learn people who are doing it
well awesome please answer that question
on Twitter and I'm super excited about
this book I'm so proud of you I'm close
to the process of you debating it and
doing it thank you so much you're real
pleasure you keep asking questions we'll
keep answering them
[Music]